congratulations what are you guys just
so excited what was your action when he
found out that good the good place was
nominated we were I mean I was thrilled
at first I got to see it come up on the
teleprompter and I said the good place
and I and I was trying to be very
even-keeled and just like not play
favorites but I I definitely my voice
went we are excited we love being on the
show we love being a part of the show we
love working together and you know any
anything that that since the beginning
we've always just sort of been like we
really like this show and every time we
find out that more people like the show
it's just kind of like icing on the cake
where were you two when he found out
that the show is nominated at the gym no
no I like my I got it I got a text like
the the group text oh oh hhhh yeah yeah
like a little like a smiley face with
just like with oh how about you
obviously you're nominated as well how
do you feel what happened what happened
to me was I I'm very philosophical the
day before hopefully I don't even know
about it because then I don't have to be
you know worried about stuff and but I
got up early for my call 5:30 and by
6:30 my Eve got the best of me sorry
well I know she's there reading it at
5:30 I thought so I googled it and
there's nothing about awards then I was
shooting we were shooting around the
corner yeah somebody came running up oh
okay yeah okay it was a big celebration
together yes your phone was fully
charged waiting for this something
someone has to tell you something you
know I do have quite a few emails to
return I love that well congratulations
to you guys I know right now you guys
are filming the final season of the good
place so what is the emotions like on
set because I'm sure it's it's difficult
it's funny
we're I think we're very aware that this
is that we're coming to a close so we're
kind of like soaking up as much time
with each other as we can you know like
there's not a lot of phone looking
there's a lot of talking and like a lot
of hanging out and and we're you know
you're we are friends so we want to
spend as much time together as possible
well today I've been on my phone a lot
you know what our job is not hard but
the words are very specific and very
kind of elevated style but the writing
for me and I know for all of us we work
our rear ends off to to come up to the
level of the words in the writing so
it's not a big prank story hahaha set
you're really working really hard to be
good in the moment so yeah and I'm bad
my goodbyes always happen after the fact
I go oh shoot it's over like a month
after yeah it's yeah yeah yeah yeah I
don't think we're I'm totally just not
even entertaining the idea that it's
actually ending I mean yeah but I mean
it is I mean it totally is and I'm gonna
face that really hard but I mean yeah I
think you know for the time being we're
just sort of I think we're just deeply
invested in the show when we want to do
a good job and we want to make sure it's
as good for the viewers as it is to us
when we read it yes so so yeah that's
that's kind of where we're at at the end
of last season Ted and his lovely wife
Mary had a party and a sleepover for the
cast so maybe we could do that again but
actually I can't plan it but our final
day's shooting is in this kind of
beautiful well I think the good place is
an incredible show and it totally
deserved to be nominated this year so
it's great that you guys got that it's
it's a great show how has this show
changed your lives I mean completely I
mean
for me it was just like I was on the
edge of trying to get out of acting
entirely and soda you know have
something come in and you know give me a
little more time was was great and I
couldn't imagine a better group of
people to be working with I mean it's
it's a you know everyone's so kind and
so talented
and so funny and you know I feel like
you know I leave here I'm gonna be
leaving the nest you know and that's you
know that's so yeah this is just been a
big hug for four years I love ya it's
changed my life in every way I think we
were in a similar boat before this show
got picked up before we got cast in the
show and so in and it's just for me it's
like a it's my literal dream come true I
mean and I'm and I mean that from the
bottom of my heart it's exactly what I
wanted to do and when I was sort of like
waiting for and hoping for yeah and you
know so the hard part is the next thing
like living up to this you know because
this has been real freaking good and for
you I'm very blessed I think and you
know if I have to get up and leave my
home and my wife and my life had better
be at this age it better be for a really
good reason because life is short and
this was a really good reason to get up
go out the door every morning because it
I feel this show has contributed
something really wonderful to the
conversation and my proof of that is
when I walk through airports and we've
all had this experience 10 11 12 13
year-olds and their parents come up and
talk to us about this show if you're
getting 12 year olds hooked on something
this bright that's really gratifying
yeah so I love that well thank you guys
so much congratulations pop some
champagne hey there we go
you